is
john marini is a professor of political
science at the university of nevada reno
and a distinguished resident fellow at
the kirby center
a senior fellow at the claremont
institute and a member of the nevada
advisory committee of the u.s civil
rights commission he served from 1987 to
88
as a special assistant to clarence
thomas who was then chairman of the u.s
equal employment opportunity commission
dr mourinho received his ba from san
jose state university and his phd in
government from the claremont graduate
school he's the author of the politics
of budget control congress the
presidency and the growth of the
administrative state and co-editor of
the imperial congress crisis in the
separation of powers please join me in
welcoming dr john marini
thank you it's nice to be back to at the
kirby center i was here before and now
i'm in residence here so that's even
better
uh
last week when i was told about this
lecture i was informed that the title of
the lecture was to be the budget battles
and the growth of the administrative
state
the publicity for the lecture had gone
out before i learned of the topic
since this is my own this is only
my second week at the kirby center i
thought i should do what i'm told
but in fact it is a good title
it brings to mind an important question
the answer to which can help elucidate
the relationship between the budget
process in the administrative state
question is this
why did the federal budget
attain unparalleled significance at the
heart of american politics
this is so not just in the last few
years
but with few exceptions
the budget process has established
itself as the
battleground
between the executive and legislative
branches in nearly every administration
since lbj's great society
the great society had attempted to
expand the public sector in an
unprecedented manner
co-opting political
administrative power that had long been
the domain of local and state
governments
but the attempt to consolidate a
centralized administrative apparatus
within the framework of of american
government was not without its problems
initially it created resistance in the
states the parties
and the electorate
and it changed the way the national
institutions the states and the
political parties related to each other
although presidents in the 20th century
had long pushed for a larger public
sector
congress with its state and local ties
had resisted
by the early 70s the real after
reorganizing itself
congress became a defender of
administrative centralization
and republican presidents appeared to be
opponents of its expansion
in terms of washington politics that had
the effect
of undermining the operation of the
constitutional separation of powers
it has made it more difficult for the
institutions to function amicably in
pursuit of a national interest
it's for this reason that the relations
between the political branches of
government congress and the president as
well
as the bureaucracy have become
increasingly hostile since the
consolidation of a centralized
administrative system it's not
far-fetched to say that the acceptance
of a modern budget system as a principal
mechanism of organizing politics
made it possible to put in place and
make operative
a distinctively american administrative
state
in america the administrative state
traces its origins to the progressive
movement
progressivism was a political movement
inspired by the political theory of
hegel known as the philosophy of history
put simply
that view presupposed the end of history
the end of philosophy and religion and
the end of politics
in short it meant there was no longer
any need
for conflict over fundamental principles
of the kind that led to political and
religious strife
the modern state itself
would be the guarantor of the rights of
man
and the embodiment of the ethical ideal
or as hegel put it the state itself
which is
rational and
which is a rational and ethical organism
should be worshipped as a secular deity
those are his words
with the end of politics the human
problem would come to be seen as a
rational or technical problem
politics would give way to
administration and hence would become
the domain
of expert knowledge
or organized intelligence as hegel
called it
the american founders in the
constitution they
framed
and was established upon a radically
different foundation
one based on nature and natural right
not history
as james madison noted factionalism is
sewn into the nature of man
therefore politics cannot be transcended
nor can philosophy or religion
so justice is the end of government as
madison said
and it remains the highest human
aspiration concerning politics
but tyranny
the opposite of political justice is
also a danger co-evil with political
life
it is human nature therefore
which makes it necessary to establish
limitations on the power of government
progressive leaders were hostile to the
constitution not merely because it
imposed limits upon the power of the
national government but because it
provided almost no role
for the central government in the area
of administration the separation of
powers inhibited the creation of a
unified will in government
and made it impossible to establish a
technical or neutral apparatus to carry
out that will
the executive budget system was among
the most important political reforms
demanded by the early progressives
a presidential budget along with party
reform would allow activist presidents
the ability to pursue the unified will
of the national majority and it would
make it possible to establish a
non-bureauc partisan bureaucracy to
carry out that will
it was not surprising therefore that the
united states was the last modern
industrial nation to adopt an executive
budget
congress was reluctant to give
presidents the authority to formulate
budgets because it was thought such
prerogative would undermine the
separation of powers
and endanger individual freedom
throughout much of american history
conflict over control of public finances
had been contained because there was a
consensus concerning the size and
purposes of the federal government
administrative functions at the national
level were few in keeping with the
federal system of decentralized
administration as well as an autonomous
civil society and a constitutional
system that underscored the limited
character of government
by the 1970s when congress reorganized
itself so as to be a major player in the
administrative process
past legislation you're familiar with
budget control campaign finance etc the
growth of the administrative state began
the process of undermining
the political
and public consensus in support of
limited government
subsequently it also eroded support for
limiting expenditures and balancing
budgets
moreover
the president and congress national
majorities and organized private
interests became rival forces and
constituencies committed to purposes
that were often impossible to reconcile
in a manner compatible with a long-term
public interest
in the 70s and 80s republican presidents
responded to and began to mobilize
majorities in opposition to the
consolidation or expansion of the
administrative state
congress long controlled by the
democratic party
now allied with the newly centralized
organized private interest developed a
stake in the maintenance and expansion
of the administrative state
the federal budget a potential
instrument for for fueling the growth of
the administrative state
subsequently came to be the point of
control from which both political
branches and both both parties
attempted to maintain expand or limit
and perhaps if you're a utopian scale
down the size of the public sector
president reagan showed that the budget
process could be used to limit spending
as well as to reduce the burden of
administrative regulations
nonetheless the failure of the national
institutions of government
and the national political parties to
achieve a new consensus or political
realignment concerning the purpose and
level of public spending by the federal
government made budget control nearly
impossible
for much of the last 50 years in an era
in which divided government has become
the rule rather than the exception the
national budget process with its taxing
spending
and regulatory authority has become the
focal point of the
american administrative state
it is the place where the where
political institutions and public
bureaucracies have attempted to
accommodate the various interests and
constituencies
seeking a share of the national wealth
the expansion of the public sector which
which accompanied the increased size of
public budgets
began a process that undermined the
distinction
between the public and private sphere
between government and civil society
subsequently became increasingly
difficult for the political institutions
to recognize the difference
between governing which required making
political choices based on available
resources
and budgeting which was simply the
provision
adequate provision for the funding of
government programs
in the last decade or so congress could
not even pass
the 13 or so appropriations bills
that constitute a budget as a result of
the ongoing use of continuing
resolutions
this actually allows the government
bureaucracy to
determine its own needs and the
necessary resources free from ongoing
and detailed political control by the
legislature
in such circumstances those supportive
of the status quo meaning the
administrative state whether in the
bureaucracy the legislative branch or
the executive branch have become a
faction on behalf of government itself
consequently there has been no effect of
national political institution that
operates on behalf of a public interest
which is responsive to the unorganized
electorate that has no access to the
administrative state and you can see
polls since this process began that the
public's confidence in the national
government has declined precipitously
over the last over 40 or 50 years in an
earlier time there was widespread
agreement that the political
institutions could tightly control
expenditures of govern budgets provided
the means of limiting claims based upon
available resources in a manner
compatible with the long-term public
good
in this period before the consolidation
of the administrative state it was
possible
to achieve a consensus concerning
budgets while limiting the costs of the
federal government's administrative
function
this was possible because they were few
in other words state and local
governments undertook most
administrative tasks there was a
bipartisan consensus concerning the
autonomy of the economic marketplace and
the distinction between the public and
private sphere
terms of
public finance limited government meant
limited and balanced budgets in normal
times
public spending and public debt were
viewed in moral terms as evils to be
avoided so as to limit the tax burden
upon the working man
federal budget process has become the
principal instrument of politics in the
american administrative state
the growing inability
to control the budget is a symptom of a
deeper crisis
which arises from
the failure of the administrative state
to function effectively because it has
not gained legitimacy
within a constitutional regime of
separated powers
in a constitutional system the powers of
government are thought to be limited
the administrative state only the lack
of resources has established any
reasonable limits on public spending
but in the last few years
those who defend or seek to expand the
administrative state have learned that
printing or borrowing money in the
absence of political constraints can
fuel almost limitless demands for public
resources on behalf of the
constituencies of the administrative
state as determined by
bureaucratic
or judicial fiat
seems the only point of opposition to
unlimited administrative growth left to
political decision makers in congress is
the apparent choice
of refusing to raise the debt ceiling
but it is difficult to stop a process
after it has been completed
with some justification i say some not
much
president obama denies that this is a
legitimate political tactic
considering that all of the institutions
have participated in the process at
every junction
not equally we could say however
it is clear that since the consolidation
of the administrative state
between 1965 and 75 both of the
political branches of government have
contributed to it to its expansion at
one time or another
but that has provided the opportunity in
the electorate
for those in support as well as those in
opposition to turn to either of the
political branches to ratify their
choice
in short there has been no consensus or
political
realignment that has succeeded in
legitimizing the administrative state so
it rests uneasily
within a constitutional structure of
limited government whose political
powers were meant to be used only on
behalf of constitutional purposes
the important question in terms of the
growth of the administrative state is
this
how did the political institutions come
to embrace the administrative state
and why has it been so hard to reverse
its direction
in my view
the decisive event was the political
transformation of congress that occurred
in the decade between 65 and 75.
it is difficult for us to remember how
congress worked and what the
expectations were concerning its role in
the constitutional order before 1965.
in a time when the presidency seemed to
dominate the political landscape
conservatives were the defenders of
congress
in 1959 james burnham in his book
congress in the american tradition
suggested that and i quote the political
death of congress would mean
plebiscitary despotism for the united
states in place of constitutional
government
and thus the end of political liberty
burnham believed that
and i quote to keep their political
liberty americans must keep and cherish
their congress
burnham chase
traced the decline of the legislative
body to the rise of the executive and
the growth of the bureaucratic state
he insisted that quote again congress
has let major policy decisions go by
default to the unchecked will of the
executive and bureaucracy this is 59
remember
in order to retain its status is first
among equals
burnham insisted that and i quote
congress must find a way to concentrate
on essentials
if it is to continue to be a partner and
peer within the central government then
its principal energies must go to
deciding major issues of policy not the
to the critique of details end quote
he assumed and this is the last quote
from
the assemblies by their very nature
cannot be bureaucratized in the modern
mode
end quote
burnham foresaw foresaw the growth of
the bureaucratic state but he did not
foresee a role for the legislative
branch within that state
was burnham right
in his assumption that legislative
assemblies could not be bureaucratized
and instead would become obsolete
that was his thesis
more than 50 years after bert john
samples a scholar at cato
assessed the role of congress in starkly
different terms
he insisted that congress has reasserted
its powers in many areas
and has proved to be more than a match
in terms of exercising that power in
defense against encroachments by the
other branches of government
he does not deny that and i quote from
him the new deal and its echoes did set
congress on a declining path toward
obsolescence
and in 1959
the administrative welfare state seemed
triumphant
had the 15 years after world war ii
continued for the next 50
burnham james burnham's bold prediction
might well have been confirmed including
the demise of congress
but the administrative welfare state
lost and never quite regained public
confidence
and if those of thwart history did not
stop its progress
they did not also fall
under its wheels that's the quote from
from samples
question remains when historians look
back at the beginning of the post new
deal will they note with surprise the
revival of the united states congress
that's what sample was asking
and he he thinks they would
but it and i don't deny that it's hard
it's hard really to deny that congress
when unified has ample power in terms of
defending itself against the other
branches
however is samples right in his
assumption that not congress but the
administrative welfare state lost
lost the confidence of the american
people is that is that right or is it
the case that congress itself had become
an integral part
of the administrative welfare state
i suggest that burnham was only partly
right in his insistence that congress
holds the key to the preservation of
political liberty in america
he assumed that his term legislative
supremacy was the fundamental condition
of the maintenance of republican
government
however the american founders did not
believe that congress as an institution
would or could be the primary defender
of liberty nor did they depend upon the
presidency nor the supreme court
exclusively to fulfill that role
the american founders established the
constitution and the separation of
powers as the surest defender of freedom
this was to be done by subordinating the
power of all political branches to their
constitutional purpose
it was the result of an event of an
abandon
of their constitutional role that made
it possible for both political branches
of government and in varying degrees
both of the political parties
to participate in the establishment and
consolidation of the administrative
state
those actions provoked their own
reaction in the electorate in opposition
to the growth and expansion of the
administrative state the electorate
turned to one or the other of the
political branches at various times
to expand or limit the administrative
state
in hindsight it appears that burnham was
wrong in assuming that assemblies cannot
be bureaucratized in the modern mode
it is only constitutional assemblies
that cannot be legitimately
bureaucratized precisely because
deliberation and general law making
remain their fundamental political and
constitutional purpose
in denying burnham's claim that congress
would cease to be a made major player in
modern government
samples has shown that a revival of
congress indicated that it had been
possible for congress to give up its law
making power
without relinquishing its authority
over those administrative body to which
it had delegated that power in other
words
it had become possible for congress to
establish itself as a major player in
the politics of the administrative state
burnham's book was written before
congress reorganized itself to
accommodate its transformation
from primarily a legislative body to an
administrative oversight body
throughout much of the 20th century
as i've said presidents of both
political parties had fought to
aggregate the administrative component
of government
pushing congress to expand the executive
branch
congress representative of local
interests still tied to state power was
reluctant to do so
it remained a defender of decentralized
administration because it insisted upon
maintaining its deliberative
and law making function
this changed in 65. i'll give you in
1965 samuel huntington professor at
harvard noted that congress could not
continue to function as a national
institution
because politically it represented
parochial and state interests
as a result he insisted that the
presidency had come to be dominant the
dominant force in national politics
and therefore and i'm quoting today's
aggressive spirit is clearly the
executive branch this is huntington in
65.
the loss of power by congress huntington
suggested and i'm quoting again
can be measured by the extent to which
congress congressional assertion
coincides with congressional obstruction
this paradox has been at the root of the
problem of congress since the early days
of the new deal
vis-a-vis the executive congress is an
autonomous legislative body but
apparently congress can defend its
autonomy
only by refusing to legislate and it can
legislate only by surrendering its
autonomy
congress can insert can assert its
powers or it can pass laws but it cannot
do both that's honey
65.
apparently huntington was convinced that
the administ that administrative
centralization
was
necessary and perhaps inevitable and
congress would have to adapt to it
there was another option for the
legislative branch
congress could
adapt itself to the requirement of a
centralized administrative state
but it could only do so if it gave up
the power to refuse
to refuse to legislate on behalf of the
administrative state
it was necessary to relinquish its
primary constitutional function of
deliberation and law making in the
national interest
and use its legislative power in the
service of the administrative state
it did so by wholesale delegation of
power to newly created administrative
and regulatory bodies whose ostensible
authority was dependent upon technical
or rational knowledge
congress could retain its autonomy
and political authority
by establishing itself as the overseer
of the executive branch
in the process individual committees and
members were empowered to oversee the
various departments and agencies the
executive branch
they would soon become major players
in the policy-making process
subsequently congress would become
an administrative oversight body
ultimately it would become in one
political science morris fiorina's
phrase keystone of the washington
establishment
constitution its separation of power
and the politics of federalism had
inhibited washington from achieving such
centralization
the progressive intellectuals had
advanced the theoretical doctrine of the
administrative state and the new deal
had attempted to expand and legitimize
the administrative state
but the administrative state was not
institutionalized in any permanent way
within the framework
of american politics until congress
reorganized itself as the keystone of
the bureaucratic state
when that occurred
from 65 to 75 the constitutional
separation of powers and the federal
system was fundamentally altered
at the time many in congress objected
objected
to the transformation one congressman
gillis long expressed the early
complaint
he noted we congress were turning ours
from an institution that was supposed to
be a broad policy making institution
with respect to the problems of the
country and its relationship to the
world into merely a city council that
overlooks the running of the store every
day end quote
now those objections were ineffectual
and short-lived
after a few years of experience members
of congress came to prefer
administrative regulation to
the liberation and legislation
representative jamie whitt summed up the
view of many in congress subsequently
when he said the smartest thing we ever
did was to throw the weight of the
federal government behind local problems
after that transformation
characteristic of the federal activity
of the federal government
and the legislature had become the
regulation or the administration of the
details of social political and economic
life in the nation
such a development could only strengthen
the organized interest and their ties to
the legislature or the bureaucracies
often at the expense of political
control of administration
even sympathetic observers of congress
the power of congress did not fail to
notice the change at that time james
sundquist who was at brookings said
as members become managers of
professional staffs
the chambers disintegrate as
deliberative bodies in the traditional
sense of legislators engaged in direct
interchange of views leading to a group
decision
with each passing year the house and
senate appears less as collect as
collective institutions and more as
collections of institutions
individual member staff groups organized
as offices and subcommittee
after the centralization of
administration
the operations and interests of the
executive and legislative branch were
fundamentally transformed
the role of the political parties was
diminished because bureaucratic
patronage would become more important
than party patron
in addition the function of the
judiciary was transformed as well
in the administrative state the
bureaucracy has no constitutional
thought but it is given enormous power
by the political branches
consequently the courts
have been required to enter the policy
making arena as the final arbiters
in the adjudication of cases arising in
the administrative process
as a result they have become fundamental
players in the political and policy
policy-making process
in legitimizing policies of the agencies
the unelected court unelected courts
have protected the political branches
from accountability
for policies that are derived almost
exclusively from the administrative
process
even when they are deeply unpopular the
electorate has no access to the centers
of power in the administrative state
congress controls the administrative
details of politics through the
bureaucracy and the judiciary reigns
supreme in the realm of political
principle
the supreme court determines what passes
for the moral will of society
by construing what passes for the
contemporary meaning of the constitution
in other words the political branches
are allowed to stray from their
constitutional purpose by the supreme
court which makes the supreme court the
fundamental arbiter what the
constitution means
insofar as congress is still tempted to
make general laws on behalf of a
perceived public good it does so
primarily
on behalf of the expansion of the
administrative state for example one in
the news right now congress passed what
appeared to be a general law concerning
health care
reform the obama administration's
patient protection and affordable care
act
but it is clear this is not a law in the
constitutional sense
it makes sense only within the context
of an administrative state
the hell free health reform bill was
more than twenty five hundred pages long
but it was not a general law
rather it established the legal
requirements
necessary to provide the administrative
apparatus with the legal right and power
to formulate the rules which would
govern health care nationwide
the extension of governmental power is
compatible with the administrative state
but it cannot be understood to be within
the letter or spirit of constitutional
government
john locke perhaps the most important
theorist of the constitution described
law as a community's
settled standing rules indifferent and
the same to all parties
emphasizing that to be legitimate a
statue must be and i'm quoting received
and allowed by common consent to be the
standard of right and wrong and the
common measure to decide all controversy
between citizens
but it is difficult to find any settled
standing rules or a meaning that is
indifferent and the same to all parties
in the health care law
in fact such laws are not meant to
protect
everyone's rights or liberty equally
as charles kessler noted in the new in
the clermont review of books at the time
that's the point of the legislation i
quote from him they start not from equal
rights but from equal and often unequal
privileges
the favors are benefits that government
may bestow or withhold from its clients
the whole point is to empower government
officials usually unelected and
unaccountable bureaucrats to bless or
curse your petition as they see fit
guided of course by their expertness in
a law
so vast
so intricate
and so capricious that it could justify
a hundred different outcomes
in the same case
as a result a government of equal laws
turns into a regime of arbitrary
privileges a privilege is literally a
private law
when law ceases to be a common standard
of right and wrong
and a common measure to decide all
controversies
then the rule of law ceases to be
republican
and becomes despotic
freedom itself ceases to be a right and
becomes a gift or the fruit of a corrupt
bargain as kessler calls it because in
such degraded regimes those who are
close to
and connected with the ruling class have
special privileges
now one can see the way obama
gave special privileges to
the congress and their staff
in other words this kind of extension of
governmental power is wholly
incompatible
with
constitutionalism but it's fundamentally
the way the administrative state
operates
in conclusion let me say that congress
is a major player in the administrative
state
but it would be difficult to say that it
performs its constitutional purpose
congress has an institution is no longer
the defender of limited government
nor is it the center of a dynamic
federal system in which the states
participated
in maintaining the political conditions
of decentralized administration
which were conducive to human freedom
more
over
the states have accommodated themselves
to centralize government and
administration they are now mere
petitioners of the federal government
the administrative state often with the
blessing of congress grew dramatically
grew dramatically in the last third of
the 20th century and it continues to
defend its turf when
and expand when
possible opposition arises in one or the
other branch depending upon circumstance
despite its expansion however under both
parties it has not attained legitimate
legitimacy within the constitutional
order
the constitution itself remains the
source of authority and legitimacy for
those in and out of government who are
opposed to the administrative state
until the administrative state becomes
legitimized
or constitutionalism delegitimized
an ongoing debate between
within the parties and the electorate
concerning the desirability of expansion
limitation or diminution of the size and
scope of the federal government is
almost inevitable
thank you
questions
uh brilliant analysis i guess the root
of a lot of problems um
so what practically speaking
do you see short-term what should we
work on to solve this problem
yeah that is the hard question
uh yeah i i mean i think
look you have opportunities in both
political branches i think
people who want to to to defend and try
to advance the constitutional purposes
of government
so
political parties
as i say they're it's hard to
we
you don't have grassroots political
parties really
the administrative state has made that
much different more much much more
difficult to utilize that as a means to
change things i mean you can see the way
the tea party
originated and yet it it appeared to
have no leadership it appeared to be
amorphous but that's the way the kind of
there's a certain kind of protest that
arises that way because there is not
really organized ways and we can see
even then the the the bureaucracy
harassed those folks
who were who were trying to utilize the
political system
to uh
to
bring about a way of thinking about this
my first the reason why i make the
arguments i made
is
i think first we have to understand what
this problem is what the depth of the
problem is
and many people in washington i think
simply do not
because you're too close to it
yeah oh sorry
anyway it it it is it is very difficult
to to first grasp in a conceptual way
what the problem is so that we know
where we can go
also then you need to be able to
convince other people
it would be nice to have leaders
periodically like ray or or somebody who
could mobilize a sentiment on behalf of
some of the try to mobilize constituency
because all of the you know the thing
about washington is it works quite well
for organized interest
it's just the unorganized public
that
has great problem with with the way
washington works and yet how do you
you've got all of the wealth
much of the will certainly that's
generated in the modern state that
that goes
toward maintaining the status quo
because there's so many benefits that
can be achieved for business
for so for uh for
social interest even religious interests
it's hard to say that they're they're
even autonomous religions that that
actually
are separate from government government
wants to fund everything
and in doing so of course it makes it
much more difficult then
to mobilize opinion in a way that's
politically affected
on behalf of opposition to that there's
a lot to be
there's a lot to be gained by those who
have access to to govern
and and
in the public at large
most people go about just living their
lives
become more they become dissatisfied but
it's very difficult i would say to start
i think it would it's important to get
people in the offices whether in the
legislative branch or the executive
branch
who understand what the problem is
and who in whatever small way because
look it took a long time to build the
administrative state it took most of the
20th century
it's not going to be
it's not going to be destroyed in a
matter of one or two or three election
cycles
it's because this administrative state
itself destroyed those institutions in
civil society
that used to accommodate the problems
that that that arose whether
there were charitable organizations or
all kinds of organizations religious
organizations that dealt with some of
the the problems of of health education
welfare and all of those other things
that that we now commonly
expect government or many people expect
government to to to
solve so those institutions
to try to you you have to be aware of
the fact that a great part of the
population is now dependent
on the these the administrative state
and it is through perhaps one could say
it's not simply their own fault
i mean those institutions were destroyed
in a in an almost systematic way
by the way in which the administrative
state thought that it was that it had a
superior way of solving the problem in
other words modern technical rational
science and social science those
traditional ways that we dealt with all
of those things
lost their authority and so people even
the family itself began to lose its
authority
uh or it certainly took a great hit
in the last 30 or 40 years
so it i i think first the first task is
try to to understand what the problem is
try to make clear
that the the depth of the problem
because it is very difficult now i think
the harder problem
that i find is not trying to understand
the administrative state because that's
within our that's the way in which we
we are taught in the universities that's
the perspective we have the difficult
problem is is to try to understand the
constitution again
in a meaningful way
now of course we all have everyone says
they're for the constitution but do they
know what it means and how to think
about it because there's a whole way of
thinking about the constitution
when you read the founders you read the
framers what what informed them their
their their opinions
and the knowledge they generated about
politics was from the philosophic
tradition
that philosophic tradition was
undermined in the 19th century we have a
tradition of thinking about this that
develops from a theory that is hostile
to the constitution
so just that whole
difficulty of trying to understand and
make meaningful what constitutionalism
would require
and and try to understand it in a way in
which
it's meaningful in which case it means
that those who
understand that are able to talk about
it in a reasonable way
you don't find many defenders of the
constitution who can make arguments
about it
they just become dogmatic too but there
are arguments there are great arguments
on behalf of the constitution once you
begin to understand
the theoretical
the way in which theory informed how
they understood pollock
this is on um
so one argument i've heard so one
solution
uh seems to be reverting back to
federalism
however one argument i've heard is that
the enforcement and implementation of
particular policies
is done better at the executive national
level
and along the lines of that argument
this person who said that
madison just not just talk about
factions on a national scale but also on
a state scale and then his reasoning is
that because factions have
intruded and influenced state
governments so much in a negative way
that in some respects
reverting back to federalism may
undermine the enforcement and
implementation of some policies that
have been
executed more efficiently on an
executive level
yeah well i i mean federalism it seems
to me
presupposes
genuine politics at other levels than
washington
there is not as far as i can see
and what that means is and and to get to
the point you're making i hear
complaints in my state in nevada
from
the political office holders political
office holders who want to do certain
kinds of things in their departments or
agencies and they find that their
departments and agencies have a
perspective that grows out of the way
the national bureaucracy understands
what i'm saying we need to have
political
political rule again
now whether it's whether it's efficient
or not i mean because the key to weather
to these bureaucracies is that they are
meant to be technically rational more
efficient we have genuine knowledge
these politicians are all
reactionaries or
but that is that that's that's
problematic it's clear that all of the
expertise
that was amassed at the level that in
the in the governments of the united
states in the 20th century have not
alleviated one human problem that
existed before and was dealt with in in
other ways
so we can't make the assumption that
technical superior or rational authority
is greater
than because they haven't proven
they take the mantle of science and
science at least has done something
but what is social science done
have they gotten rid of crime
have they gotten rid of all of the
things that were so-called poverty all
the things that they would that that was
thought that the rational state the the
state with all of this if we turn it
over to experts are going to solve the
problem
seems to me where
they haven't done it so
i think what you have to do is
re-establish genuine politics at other
levels
now tocqueville pointed to this early on
in democracy in america when he said
problem is people won't participate in
politics if the power to solve the
problems is not there they're not stupid
you're not going to try to deal with the
problems in your local government that
were in your state if you know that
those problems are solved in washington
how do you get and what that leads to
according to tocqueville is
people will become increasingly
apathetic
they won't exercise their rights in a
responsible way
they won't be good citizens because they
will be contemptuous of politics
and they will return they'll turn
themselves back into their private
affairs and become wholly absorbed in
their private affairs and you don't want
citizens of a
of of a republic not to be vigilant
remember remember federalist 57 madison
says
you know what's to keep congress
from making laws
that
that
treat them differently than
than the population as a whole he says
they can madison says they can make no
law which is not fall equally on
themselves but then he says he knows
perfectly well they can
he knows he said but he said what's
going to prevent it
the vigilant and manly spirit
of the citizens and he says if they ever
put up
with congress making laws and exempting
themselves from it they'll put up with
anything but but freedom
so you know you have to
you have to
you have to get people interested in
politics but become responsible in how
they think about politics they must be
reasonable
when they think about politic
everybody thinks only in terms of
interest now or other
categories
and these categories become fundamental
whether it's race class any of these
things are fundamental
and if those are more fundamental than
the possibility of of
of
of deliberation or or accommodation and
compromise then then self-government
doesn't have much
future
the presupposition of the american
founding
presupposition of of the role of
congress is it's a deliberative body
because
the deliberative body
requires what the liberation
what is the common denominator that
makes the liberation possible
reason
public reasoning
you have to give arguments
and it's so rare to find politicians
that are that are capable of doing
and yet now i if
see my arguments are somewhat
theoretical
the the modern state in other words the
administrative state is actually
predicated on the assumption that will
should replace reason
that's why they hated the separation of
powers people like woodrow wills
because it did not enable a particular
the will to dominate
and for
for wilson and all of the progressives
of course that meant
that once the parties and the president
establish a will
then it's simply a matter of carrying
out that will
but the american founders knew
they knew
that
will can be used to radically
will that's why they wanted to prevent
unified will they wanted congress to
deliberate
and and legislate
and they knew that that was not
the whole of the necessity of government
they knew there had to be energy in
government and the ability to make
decisions so they put
they put they unified the executive and
gave the executive power but the
executive is meant to use the will in on
behalf of the execution of public
reasons
so there's a complicated way in which
all of this fits together
separation
thank you
professor
excellent talk hopefully you will make
the written remarks available on the
website
i'm a staff with the american legion
it's a veterans organization formed in
1919 after world war one of world war
one veterans coming home from uh from
europe
it's a mutual help organization but it's
also a lobbying organization
we have lobbied for many decades to
create the department of veterans
affairs
it is now the second largest federal
agency
a 130 billion dollar budget
my concern is as a civil society
organization as a public association
with the growth and expansion of the
department of veterans affairs whether
that actually
takes the lifeblood out of an
organization a membership organization
like the american legion as veterans
then turn to the va rather than to an
organization like the american legion
such that the dismantling of the
administrative state would actually
return lifeblood to a membership
organization and ensure the the future
growth of an organization like the
american legion
yeah i think that's right
i mean that's the point i mean the
problem is once you
once you
once you create an administrative excuse
me
administrative agency all of the focus
goes there
and it and in some ways those who are
best served are those that have access
to that
and and increasingly of course the
professional staffs and and all of those
really
they they
they destroy they they undermine the
possibility of the spontaneity that
originates in the activity of diverse
members who can work together without
that without that structure
so i mean
in in in civil society associations they
of necessity have to work together
in government associations all you have
to do is get a budget
get an allocation then you create a
whole new world and there's no incentive
for anybody that's in any agency that
that has
that gets expenditures ever to
do anything but try to increase
the expenditures that they have at their
disposal there is no incentive for force
for
you're not a good manager in in an
agency if you tell people well i
actually cut my budget last la this this
year
i actually
that means you're a failure in a certain
way right
but
in in
private organizations are capable of
responding better to needs and
circumstances
that's what i mean about the kind of
spontaneity kind of
uh there's something in civil society
that that you can't calculate because
because you don't know what it is
because the possibilities arise from
many things that that that that give
life
so it is it i think that what it will
take a while let's assume that you're
that we did get rid of some of these
kinds of agencies it would take a while
before people would begin to understand
that they had to solve these problems
themselves necessity is a great stir
there's a great spur really to action
and when people find it
when it's necessary for them to do i
think we'd be surprised just as you look
in the free and in the mar in the free
market
in any kind of activity where there is
no
kind of rational coordinated effort
you see a great deal of
of of
of
innovation
you see a great deal because people are
trying to think of ways to get things
done
and and and when you
when you institutionalize something you
tend to do things the way they were done
before
and it and and it becomes really an
impediment to innovation
even success itself as people like peter
drucker in the management field of show
success itself
ultimately
prevents big companies from being able
to adapt in a way because they're so
used to success and they do things that
can
lead to success that they fail to see
how things are changing
and they don't adapt and then they they
end up
losing
their share of the market to those
companies that do see new needs new
necessities so it's it's a it's a
different kind of world uh
the bureaucratic world
and it's going to be hard i think to
revitalize the institutions of civil
society
but one thing that is always
possible that you have to be prepared
for
by having knowledge of of these things
there's always going to be some crisis
that
necessity reimposes itself because in
the west for a long time i think we've
just we've deceived ourselves into
thinking that we've created reality
through our decisions rather than there
is a reality and that reality one day
will impose itself
reimpose itself
when the foolishness of the decisions
that have been made over a long period
of time
come to be incapable of being continued
so
reality is always the real
check i think